j'ai un regret c'est que c'est vrai que
je n'ai jamais vraiment rencontré dione
idée mais pourtant un jour on était sur
le même plateau jeux j'allais faire le
morning live sur m6 et forcément m6 m'a
demandé de faire un petit peu de promo
parce que j'ai démarré le lundi avait
une émission qui était propre et très
populaire qui s'appelait le hit machine
avec charly et lulu et charly et lulu me
disent on va inviter pour faire la promo
du morning live
je suis absolument inconnu donc je me
retrouve sur le plateau de charly et
lulu
ils me disent au dernier moment à laon
deuxième invité il y aura johnny en
deuxième invité de radio j oui donc tu
es d'invités et moi il y aura johnny qui
venaient à voir mais johnny hallyday oui
oui johnny lille et vanilla et je me
suis retrouvé avec charly et lulu et
johnny hallyday en train de faire un
plateau je sais pas ce que je faisais là
j'étais à côté de jaunisse et une de
voilà je démarrais le morning après et
vous allez voir chaque côté de johnny et
logan est pas bien regarde là sur le
plateau d'une machine je répète voici
johnny
vous ouvrez vous regardez nous dit pas
ce qu'il ya dedans de jeudi s'il vous
plaît un boudin noir du bouddha j'adore
le bo d'apurer sa souvenirs d'enfance
mais dans le restaurant est ce qu'il y
en a oui il y en a j'ai fait mettre du
bouddha pure est pas parce qu avant ils
n'avaient pas à bryant n'avait pas donc
j'ai créé à beaucoup et il fallait oui
il faut à plat avec du goût des jeunes
yal'idée m le bouddha puis messieurs en
exclusivité m6 ne sais quoi que johnny
est amorphe il est là parce qu'il ya une
odeur et ça quelque chose souligne haute
et je préfère les vraies chaussures les
longues
je n'avais jamais organisé leur mac
avaient avec eux et un tchèque un moment
mais il était c'était un amour en
franchement c'est un amour ne
connaissais pas du tout il rigolé avec
moi ils se prêtaient c'est son
intelligence il se prêtait à toutes les
allégations évidemment hélas hélas les
grands talents au hall aime vraiment